welcome back to Las Vegas now in today's
legal minute Eric Palacios from Eric
Palacios and Associates the sponsors of
this segment shares what are three
things you need to know about a u Visa
hi I'm attorney Eric Palacios welcome to
the legal minute the question we're
going to answer today is if you're an
immigrant what are three things you need
to know about the U Visa number one the
U Visa was created to help victims of
certain crimes involving physical or
mental abuse there are only ten thousand
U visas allowed per year number two the
crime must have taken place in the
United States or be a crime in this
country and number three you must
cooperate with authorities in
Prosecuting the aggressor this means you
should fill out a police report and if
necessary testify against that person or
the person that committed the crime U
visas take about seven or eight years to
be approved it's a long and tedious
process if you think you may qualify
it's important to talk to an experienced
immigration attorney this has been the
legal minute we'll see you next time
give Eric Palacios and Associates a call
or visit their website at Eric
palacioslaw.com we'll be right back